don't accept BS answers so I'm recording
this video again i did this video
initially as a blab blab stop sending me
recordings and it didn't actually record
what i wrote which is super frustrating
and i'm a big believer in making videos
when i'm in the moment when i'm excited
or frustrated about something and I try
to do it on book day so i can give you
something that's relevant in contextual
so we actually missed the book video
last weekend because it didn't come out
properly the message that i was talking
about was not accepting BS answers and
i'll do my best to kind of get back into
my frustrated state of mind that i was
in before but i think what happens a lot
of times is people at first glance don't
want to give you the real answer people
don't want to tell you the real problem
behind why something is not happening
and this was happening in my book where
didn't want to put logos and pictures in
the book as an example and they were
telling me that well book buyers don't
want to buy it if there's pictures in it
and first of all how many books have a
picture in it and second of all you know
because there's a logo on page 43 that
means a book buyer is not going to want
to buy the book come on that's a BS
answer and so somebody tied to the you
know to the publishing company that I'm
working with was talking about this and
I had to call them I was like that's a
BS answer you know that's not the real
reason why you don't want the pictures
in there often what you have to do is
dig deeper when you're having
conversations finally the real reason
behind the reason I think people will
often try to cover things up and it
happens in a lot of different situations
I'm thinking about one of the
entrepreneurs that I'm mentoring right
now and how he's trying to grow and
build himself up and I had to call him
on a lot of the BS that he tells himself
to write like I can't do this because of
XYZ like that's just BS you're just
afraid and having a dig deeper to why
he's afraid to then help him get over
that hurdle and solve the problem and so
I think very very very often if you're
dealing with a customer supply or
investor media or employees or
anybody who relates to your business
very very often the default answer that
people give you is not the truth is
covering something that mostly cuz they
may they may not want to hurt you or
because they have some deep fear that
they don't want to acknowledge or share
or did I want to get into a long deep
conversation think about how often you
just say when somebody asks you hey how
you feeling today you just say yeah I'm
good I'm good for meanwhile you're not
like there's a ton of crap happening but
you just don't want to go deeper into it
because it's not worth that time for you
and so your job as the entrepreneur to
go deeper is to make that person feel
comfortable to explain themselves to
want to go and have a bigger
conversation and sometimes to call them
out on their BS and say listen tell me
the real reason because if you want to
get something done and it's not
happening you got to get to the core
reason and not just accept other
people's BS I kind of got a little
excited I was much more upset when I
first recorded it but feel like I still
gave you something there cool let's get
to the questions which I already
answered as well but I'm feeling it and
want to give you guys some value to help
for guys hey Evan we love the content
you're putting out a book around this
it's building are insufficient we can't
wait until you put it out thank you for
that I appreciate it do you have any
tips for delegation when you don't have
employees may be virtual assistants
outsourcing of some kind yeah I think
one of the biggest mistakes that people
make is feeling like they have to hire
somebody full-time right away don't hire
somebody full-time right away especially
we've never managed anybody before you
want to work your way into it you're
going to make a lot of mistakes it's
gonna suck up one more time than you
think it will you're probably gonna hire
the wrong person to start with and so
don't go hiring somebody full times also
a lot more expensive the first person I
hired was for one hour day that's it one
hour day to do database work for me that
freed up more than an hour of my time of
day because he was better at it than I
was and that's how you start right now I
hire most of my new people threw up work
it's a system designed for getting
people remotely then a built a great
team I love the people that I'm working
with now some people work full-time some
people work part-time overall on my team
were up to 19 people working on my 20th
higher right now
and I recommend it I mean you need
people to help you build this thing up
you can't do everything yourself and I
know it's frustrating and I know finding
the right people can can suck a lot of
times just the process sucks but when
you find that right person man it makes
a world of difference and it's
definitely worth it next Mira Choi hello
i'm new subscriber to your channel it's
been great to see everything you've
informed me for the past two months
welcome to believe nation mira i was
wonder if you had a chance to create a
video in the near future but resumes
interviews prioritizing a change in a
career this comment has nothing to do
with this video but as I'm going through
that change it'd be good if I had some
resources you know you're right I don't
really talk much about resumes and
interviews I think the job hiring
process is broken and I've done some
videos on how I hire and this hatchet
eyes well the last question I think the
most important thing if you are looking
at becoming you taking on a job is that
you're going to learn right you take a
job to learn whether your eventual path
is to be an entrepreneur or you want to
see a crew employee you want to be in a
place where you feel like you're
learning every day and I think a lot of
people are in jobs with are not learning
anymore and that's when they get
frustrated that's one they kind of give
up that's when they're living for the
weekends and evenings and so the
challenge for you is to identify when
you're going through the job process is
this a company that I can learn at and
usually the biggest factor is is this a
boss that I can learn from right you
look at job satisfaction like a growth
it's mostly coming from your immediate
boss do they look out for you to the
support you do they try to teach you new
things and if you feel like you're
learning growing from them then that's
high on job satisfaction and if you like
they don't care about you then it
usually leads to a lot of
dissatisfaction your job this may sound
corny but I would challenge you to try
to be yourself take a little bit more
risk show a little bit more personality
I think people are just living the
photoshop versions of themselves
everybody is friendly everybody has you
know these fake resumes you go through
the job interview process and you're on
your best behavior and you don't really
get to know the people in more detail
you don't get to show your personality
enough and so I would rather that
somebody
he loves me or hates me because
eventually I'm going to have to work
with that person and I want them to know
me and I don't want to be surprised
later on right it's like it's like
you're getting married to somebody
without really knowing who they are and
then you hope that it works out if it
were me applying for a job I would be I
would I would be bold I would take risks
on my resume I would say things that
reflect my true personality that make me
stand out that people look at that
resume and say that's nuts or that's
nuts right I want people to get excited
or hate it I'm the same thing when I do
a job interview I would be myself I
would have bold opinions I would do my
research on the company I would have
suggestions for where they could grow I
would be upfront and honest and what I
expecting and what I wanted to try to do
and build their if you really value the
the team aspect then I would make that
front foremost if you really value
having an impact I would make that front
and foremost if you really value
learning and growing I would make that
front and foremost so that they know
because if they're an organization and
like if you're someone who really values
teamwork is this is Nina is my wife she
loves teamwork she loves a team it's
super important to her if you're someone
who really values teamwork and you go
win leading with teamwork and how like
this is the biggest thing for you and
you you're applying to a company where
they don't really carry too much about
teamwork by you putting that front and
center then you'll get you won't get
brought back right because you're not a
fit with what they're trying to do and
that's awesome like I would hate to go
through three stages of interviews only
to find out later that I'm not a fit or
even worse get hired into the company
and then feel like man I chose the wrong
company because again I was just a
Photoshop version of myself I didn't say
what I was really about and so I think
people look too much at just the skills
and the experience and the paper and the
credentials and the background and not
enough about the values and the goals
and most employers do a terrible job of
communicating that to you look at most
job descriptions and they're boring and
corporate and terrible and just they
look like everything else and so if it
were
again i would i would have radical
self-expression and i would want in
every interaction from my resume to my
cover letter to my every job interview
that i go through with that company to
be fully myself and have them either
love me or hate me you think I didn't
not have a lot to say but I kind of went
on a rant their next shabba I'll be
buying tons of your book when it's out
so well done you've come a long way
while i'm at the beginning of my journey
shabba first of all thank you for that I
appreciate the love and support in the
book everybody's on their journey that's
cool right i mean i think what a lot of
people do too often is compared they're
big they're beginning to somebody else's
middle like don't look at me and and get
depressed about how you're not where i
am yet you're at the start that's
awesome if you can use it as motivation
like i want to get there that's great
but i think too many people get
discouraged too much by looking at where
somebody else at is that and feel like
they should be there where you're just
at the start and they've already been
doing this for years sometimes decades
so I appreciate support I'm excited for
your journey and you look forward to the
updates Peter how can one drive traffic
to their free download in my case is an
excel file but it could be an e-book as
well I created a file that helps
students in high school understand taxes
better in the future I want to create
files for teachers as it's free i don't
have any marketing money i love to hear
your thoughts on this subject Peter
linked to the question this is a tough
one not in the execution just like
you're dealing with a topic that most
people don't care about you want to talk
to students about taxes that's something
that most students just don't care about
you need to create the demand by showing
why they should care and I would try to
tie it into something that they do care
about like if they really love Beyonce
then tie something beyonce is going
through about taxes or tie her opinions
on taxes something she said you know I
just came back from Madrid and helping
librarians try to connect with the
younger generation about reading and one
of the things I talked about was Will
Smith who got up and won an award and
said the secret to life is running and
reading and why he loves reading so much
you know for a lot of youth who don't
care about reading but may look up the
will smith that's a great message to use
he will to reach them and so you have to
start trying to create the demand by
tyne into something that is more
important to them I would still also
challenge you to think is there and is
there a better message that you can have
something that that they might care more
about I don't know why you chose taxes
that's something like insanely dear to
your heart I don't know the backstory
behind this you're facing that uphill
battle in general though if you're
trying to get people to download your
white paper your excel file your ebook
you want to create compelling content
around it right you know I have a
newsletter attached to my youtube
channel that's in the description and
it's on the end card of most of the
videos so you can learn about me and
sign up for whatever your programs I'm
promoting to the newsletter so you can
create YouTube videos if you're great on
camera you can create a blog post with
bonus material if you're great at
writing you can use facebook and twitter
and instagram if you're great at
creating short content so i would be
leveraging points that people do care
about provide some value not just hey
sign up for my free whatever but you
have to provide some value first to
build trust so they know you like you
trust you you know did they appreciate
you they want to make time for you
because getting somebody's email is a
personal thing right you've started a
relationship so if they give me a reason
to do that I need to trust you first
because there's too many scammers then
if you looking at trying to connect the
teachers I love that idea and I'd be
trying to look at are there what
associations or unions or organizations
can I be a part of learn from connect
with so that instead of me trying to
connect with one teacher at a time I'm
connecting with one person an
organization and their helped me connect
to thousands of teachers at a time Dave
lalito 480p he's referencing that to my
old video was 40 p yeah sorry bro i love
the rising standards i love that you you
care about the quality of the videos i
just found it easy to do it via blab and
blab records i guess in 480p and i just
uploaded that to my channel although it
didn't work last week so here i am
recording on my home camera and it's
hopefully higher quality than 40 p
kristaps dig
I love your channel because every day
there's something new to watch thank you
for that I appreciate the love I'm
pyramid craftsman and seller on ebay
etsy amazon I feel great in days when I
have five or more orders but I feel down
on my luck in days when I'm 024 orders
and I start to compare myself to others
from my point looks like everybody is
doing more than me question what to do
in those days when I have no orders and
how to get out of comparing mindset
please let me know video is the answer
thank you very much for all the hard
work you're doing this is a tough one
and I don't i won I don't know that that
that is that bad a thing if you can use
it to motivate you I think having a goal
having a number like I want to hit five
sales a day is motivating in that it
makes you want to go out and get those
five sales a day right if you don't have
a go and say oh I'm gonna do whatever
you know I'm just going to try to make
some sales then you're you're more
likely to underperform that's typically
how goals work they work when they're
measurable their specific and they
motivate you to keep going I think what
I would add to that though is not have
that be the only goal that you're doing
I would try to look at what are the
inputs that lead there like what what
are the what's the work that you do to
get those sales so maybe you're you know
making YouTube videos maybe you're
creating your newsletter maybe you're
reaching out to the media may be trying
to form partnerships and you have goals
around those as well so you know I want
to make one YouTube video per week I
want to reach out to five potential
partners per week and then you can start
checking off those things so you feel
good about them too so that even if you
don't necessarily hit your five sales a
day you're doing all the things that you
need to do to be successful and that if
you keep doing those you'll you'll be
successful and hit those goals
consistently and then that five cells a
day might go to 10 sales a day 20 sales
a day and upwards and onwards the other
thing I would say about that is I would
try to create an environment for
greatness I would try to look at what my
routines are my habits are what's around
me things that make me want to think
bigger things that motivate me you know
it can be really hard you know as an
entrepreneur you know I don't know your
status but as a solo entrepreneur may be
working from home doesn't have an
entrepreneurial environment around them
you know the only thing that makes you
feel good is hitting those five sale
today I would love to see you have
something that builds you up every
single morning whether it's watching the
top 10 videos whether it's watching the
interested series whether it's reading a
book from our entrepreneur look up to
and respect because I feel too many
entrepreneurs don't have a great
environment they don't have people
around them who are encouraging them and
supporting them the only thing that you
attach your value to your self worth as
a human being is getting those five
sales a day and so you take it
personally it's rough on you when you
don't hit those five whereas if you were
to create rituals and habits and consume
things every single day that made you
believe in yourself and made you
confident then you're much more likely
to one set bigger goals and have bigger
stakes and believe in yourself more and
to by learning from these famous
entrepreneurs and their past failures
and their setbacks early on it gives you
at least it gave me the motivation to
keep going even when times look you
knows all darkness around you and times
like it looks like you're going to fail
those stories really motivated me so I
hope you can apply some of that to your
daily routine to gel how do i create a
business helping other businesses
survive and expand well i haven't run a
company before this is something like
doing because we have to do a business
school the short answer is go and run a
company you got to understand that you
know making money is about providing
value and providing value is about
having the experience to know what is
valuable or not and so you could learn a
lot from your business school and I'm
sure it's helping some entrepreneurs but
you want to get more experience really
quickly right if your end goal is to
work with companies or acquire companies
and turn them around and build
businesses then you need to know all the
different scenarios I had my biggest
education in looking at a lot of
different kinds of businesses after I
sold my first company and i joined the
venture capital firm because all I was
doing was seen another business plan
another business find another business
plan and then the companies came in and
I learned how these VCS broke down the
businesses in like a second because they
seen it so many times and these guys
were all in their 60s
70's and here i was having only built
and sold one business in one industry
and now I had a breadth of knowledge
from them haven't done this for so many
years ain't seeing all these businesses
come in that that really catapulted my
knowledge base forward that combined
with reading up about successful
entrepreneurs same which entrepreneurs
trying to model them constantly every
day looking at new videos and read new
books trying to get new information and
wisdom and so you need to be able to
provide more value and that comes from
getting experience what I would honestly
do if I were you is try to find a
company that you look up to that you
want to be like in a few years 10
employees or less go work for them try
to get your hands in as many project as
possible learn learn learn learn learn
why you're getting paid to learn and
make mistakes and on the side start your
own business helping companies and maybe
you don't charge at the beginning maybe
because you can't provide enough value
me because you don't know what to tell
them and as you get more experience and
you provide more value you'll be able to
start charging you can start building up
your repertoire and when you get to the
point where you have enough income
coming in from your part time business
to support yourself and you stop
learning at the other company then you
quit you go full time it may not be the
answer that you want to hear but you
need to be able to get the experience
and the knowledge you provide the value
so you can go help these businesses out
Cathy love all your work Thank You Kathy
I'm one if you do motivational speaking
as well I I do a fair amount of speaking
I don't try to promote it too much
because from a lifestyle point of view I
don't like being away from home that
much my wife misses me too much and i
miss 02 it's hard on us when i'm away
too much and so I don't I try not to be
away too much I don't consider what I do
motivational speaking I guess it is but
I don't label myself as a motivational
speaker and I also try to pick projects
where I feel like I can have an impact I
want to I want to understand the cause
and I want to play an important part in
it and I put a lot of pressure on myself
because if I'm spending you know I just
I went to Madrid and did the speaking to
help the librarians if I'm spending a
week away and they're paying me for it
right I get paid to go and they pay
nicely what's
I'm spending a week away from all the
stuff that I'm doing here right a week
away from helping entrepreneurs in my
city a week away from my normal daily
activities I better make account like it
better better change those librarians
lives because otherwise I've wasted my
time and I don't care that I got paid
for it my biggest metric of success is
feeling like I'm having an impact those
two things combined of putting in seeing
pressure on myself to do a really good
job and help them with I'm trying not to
be a way too much means that I don't do
too much speaking but I'm open to it for
the right causes Cornelia absolutely i'm
excited to buy the book Evan you're
doing an awesome job I get blessed all
the time Thank You Cornelia I really
appreciate that I'm really feeling the
love Murphy great advice is always go
jays go we're going to win it this year
I'm a big Blue Jays fan when I did the
original recording that had my blue jays
had on it was really timely I forgot to
put my hat on because I forgot this
comment was in here Murphy thank you for
that I agree I don't know that Jays are
gonna win it all I hope they will it's
looking not that great early in the
season but it's still early and
appreciate the love on the channel Pete
working with that passion i love it a
fun question would you ever go out of
your comfort zone to learn beep ball
beep ball is baseball blindfolded not
hitting the ball with your eyes but with
your ears can you do it we'd love to see
this have a great day interesting
question and i'm going to give you may
be a different take on it i love doing
things that push my comfort zone I think
that's what you learn I think that's
where the fun is I think that's where
you know if you can if you can push
yourself out of what you're afraid of
doing then you learn and grow and you
you bring more to the world and you just
feel more awesome I don't know I when
I'm afraid of something I try to look at
why if I can think about it and then I
try to do it and so I'm not a I'm not
afraid of doing beat ball it's also just
not a goal of mine you know if somebody
came up that was local and said hey do
you want to do beat ball today you got
to hit the ball with your ears then i
would say sure let's give it a shot and
see how it goes but it's also not on my
to-do list i think there's other things
that I that I'm actually afraid of that
would stretch me
the more that that I'm going to try and
so I think it's an important i think
it's not refer as we tend to do that in
a lot of ways and push ourselves to
learn more to diet to dig deeper but we
all have limiting beliefs and we all
have fears and when you can conquer some
of those that's when you really start to
see growth in your business but also in
your life as a human being fun with
Wesley hi Evan and Nina our families
trying to start our own business and
home based income streams and whatever
we get discouraged I usually look for
something encouraging on your channel
you have so much great and encouraging
content thanks for all you do Nina come
come join there she is hey there's Nina
we got joined into it's the whole
family's here thank you for the support
thank you for this thank you for the
support and and and honestly like you
guys your comments your love is what
keeps us going to keeps me going Nina
spends a lot of time in the comments too
it's it's just amazing to wake up every
day and see more great comments for me
impact is what motivates and drives me
and so knowing that it's having an
impact in your lives for all of you all
of you are leaving great comments means
the world to me and to all of us so I'm
gonna wrap it up there it's chaos here
thank you guys for watching I'd love to
know your thoughts on the topic topic at
the start was don't accept BS answers
let me know what you think if you have a
question too about the book my book the
book writing process that I can help you
with leaving the comments below I'll
join a discussion thank you guys again
continue to believe and I'm hungry too
and we'll see you soon you're silly mr.
you are a silly monkey did you know that
did you know that you're a silly monkey